in a month's time the American public
will go to the polls for the midterm
elections for many this is a referendum
on Joe Biden's first two years in the
White House and if the polls are to be
believed it won't be good news for the
Democrats what remains clear is that
American politics is still incredibly
divisive so what's at stake well in the
House of Representatives everything
435 congressional districts some are
solidly Republican some are solidly
Democrat but there are a few that can be
flipped and the Republicans know that a
net gain of just five seats will give
them control of the chamber that would
mean Nancy Pelosi is no longer the
speaker pushing through the president's
agenda she would be replaced by a
republican almost certainly Kevin
McCarthy in the Senate 35 of the 100
seats are up for grabs but only 10 of
those are thought to be competitive at
the moment both sides have 50 seats with
tie breaks decided by the casting vote
of the democratic vice president now
both sides know that a net gain of just
one will give them control of the
chamber
traditionally the president's party
doesn't do well in midterms Donald Trump
lost 40 House Seats Barack Obama lost 63
in his first midterm so what are the key
issues for voters first there's
inflation the cost of everything seems
to be going up and not just the basic
cost of foodstuffs and wages aren't
rising at the same level the economy is
most people's number one concern
there's also the cost of filling up your
vehicle it's expensive and with OPEC
announcing production Cuts it's going to
get more expensive just as people are
going to the polls so it's all bad news
for Democrats right well not necessarily
the Supreme Court's decision to overhaul
abortion rights in the United States has
led to more women and Democrats
registering to vote they believe the
only way to protect abortion is at The
Ballot Box and the Democrats also see
the polls that suggest Americans want to
restrict access to some weapons and they
believe that the only way to do that is
to give them a majority in the midterm
elections
if the polls are to be believed then the
Republicans could well win the house and
just fall short in the Senate but if
we've learned one thing over the last
six years it is that American politics
is highly unpredictable